welcome everybody this is DNA star my
name is Matthew Kaiser i'll be
presenting our software to you today
we're going to be looking at some exome
data sets and some some data for
assembling using our sequin engine
assembler and doing some downstream
analysis oh if you have some questions
please post them and we'll answer them
at the end of the webinar today so to
start out I thought I'd give a little
introduction to DNA star we are located
in Madison Wisconsin we have a nice
picture here of the lake and the capital
our sales team our development team is
located in Madison Wisconsin and that
allows us to provide excellent support
for the software if you are familiar
with our software already you'll know
that we've been in business for quite
some time and we're known for excellent
support of software and producing very
powerful software programs our history
goes back quite a few years our founder
is dr. Fred blattner his lab sequence
the e coli genome in the mid-1990s fred
is plays an active role with the company
yet and we've been producing software
for life scientists for since 1984 our
focus has been mostly desktop computing
in the past windows and macintosh
computers but more recently we've
offered software on the cloud as well as
some of our assembly software on linux
computers so DNA start does produce
research-grade software on this slide we
can see dating back to nineteen
eighty-five the number of citations in
research journals for for our software
and you can see that DNA star all the
way up until 2012 as more than twice the
number of citations as our nearest
competitor so while our software is
desktop driven we design it to be as
easy to use as possible yet powerful
enough for you to use
in your research and and your
publications so one of the first
questions that will come up with desktop
software especially when we're talking
about next-gen sequence data is is the
software gonna be powerful enough to
meet all of our needs and I like to show
this benchmarking which is available
also on our website and there's some
additional benchmarks there as well and
this shows a reference guided assembly
some data sets from human genome to
exomes to RNA seek and with both alumina
and ion torrent data and we can see that
I've got exomes highlighted here and
this is a data set of over a billion
reads so it's multiple exomes and the
assembly time is about 14 hours so it's
a bit under two hours per exome human
genomes again this is over a billion
reads almost 40 X coverage in about 12
hours and so we've developed software
that takes full advantage of all the new
hardware improvements so it'll it will
use RAM and disk space and and the CPUs
and some of the newer computers and
produce really nice fast assembly time
so so this software we feel is really a
viable option to using linux clusters or
relying on you know your bioinformatics
group and a big Linux computer to run
these assemblies we feel that budget
desktop computers can provide excellent
of performance and sometimes I'll
perform much larger computers so the way
that the hardware is organized is a just
a couple of components that you would
need to have the hardware configured a
core computer of these days a 16
gigabyte RAM computer with four to eight
cores isier is your computer you can buy
best buy for you know a couple thousand
dollars and and so this could be a
sturdy laptop more often it's a desktop
computer and the processor matters and
you need a chunk of
am but certainly nothing to
high-performance here and you need
enough disk space to process of some of
the data as it's being fed into the
assembler and this is really the key
component for our software is that you
eating enough disk space dedicated to
handling the temporary files that are
generated during assembly and then of
course you need storage and that storage
can be on the network an internal drive
to the computer or an external drive it
doesn't matter and this will give you
optimal performance and so a setup like
this that will recommend the customers
again can be well under two thousand
dollars so very minimal hardware
investment easy to set up and you're
ready to start assembling data sets you
know as large as exomes or even given
genomes so another aspect to the
software is the excellent support in the
fact that we have our development team
are scientists located here in Madison
along with most of our sales staff that
means that that we can answer all of
your questions we can provide feedback
to the development team so that if you
have some enhancement requests or if
you're on the cutting edge of some new
type of sequencing project we can relay
that that information back to the
development team what I have here is a
sudden some screenshots of our website
our website contains many useful links
to information that includes a long list
of short demo videos on a variety of
different topics so we have some
next-gen workflows that cover a variety
of different workflows and sequencing
platforms as well as things like snippet
ection and assembly and analysis and
we'll cover quite a few of these things
in today's webinar as well these whip
these videos are a great resource you
know if you need some help on you know
just a small aspect of your assemble you
can look here and usually find the help
that you need we also offer more
in-depth webinars similar to what we're
doing today except that these are
usually live in the saw
for webinars where we'll open up the
software and go through a workflow from
assembly to downstream analysis and so
there's a number of archived webinars
and they can cover non next-gen topics
as well our last webinar was cloning in
primer design we've we have some new
products for protein folding as well as
excuse me as well as some next-gen
topics from microbial genomes to Exim
assemblies so again these are great
resources if you want to learn what the
capabilities are in our software so
there are a number of different software
packages that we offer and today we're
going to be talking mostly about the
laser gene genomic sweet and alleging
genomic sweet is you can think of it as
three three pieces one piece is the
assembler the assembler Siegman engine
is typically set up on a more powerful
computer like the one that at that I
showed in the earlier slide and it
produces output files that then can be
analyzed in our seek manner erased our
software so we include our lazy gene
core and arrays start in this genomics
package so if what you see today
interests you and you have a need for
this type of software it's the genomic
sweet that you would want to inquire
about we also have other sweets that
focus on structure and proteins as well
as multiple sequence alignments and more
basic tools like cloning and primer
design and also a new program in over
fold which introduces some some new
capability for prediction of protein
folding so again wide-ranging
functionality we can customize the
different pieces to really fit your
needs if you have more questions you can
certainly visit our website or contact
us after the webinar so our next end
software supports most workflows and
that includes things as far ranging as
genomic sequencing to 16s RNA to RNA see
de novo transcriptome we have a
bacterial genome closure workflow that
is very unique to DNA star and it
actually automate some of the work
difficult aspects of genome closure is
we have some recorded webinars on our
website to cover these topics but today
we're going to focus on an excellent
atta set and a data set that we'd i
downloaded from the short read archive
so it's in the public domain and we're
just going to use that as our dental set
today just to kind of show off some of
the tools and the software so with these
type of experiments at one of the main
challenges is really finding software
that's flexible enough to accommodate
different type of projects that you're
going to have and so the software has to
be flexible enough to accommodate you
know from just a handful to hundreds if
not thousands of different samples in
each sample may contain tens or hundreds
of millions of sequence reads and it can
be anywhere from thousands to hundreds
of thousands of variations that can be
detected in each one of those samples so
the the challenge really becomes how do
I analyze such a large amount of data
and do it efficiently and feel confident
that you know what I'm doing you know is
really finding the variations of
interest and just to give you an idea in
human genome assemblies it's common to
get up to 4 million variations / human
genome that you sequenced and so this
massive amount of data again needs to be
filtered down in a simple way so that
you can find it might be one or handful
of either snips or it may be genes that
are related to the disease or condition
of interest and so what I hope to show
today is just kind of the flow here to
go from lots of variations to relatively
few so the data set that we're going to
work with again comes from the short
read archive so this is a group from the
University of Washington from the
department of genome sciences and this
is a data set we could download so it
was it was a nice data set to use and we
know what the answer is more or less and
we know that there's a each one of these
exomes contain
about 200 novel nonsynonymous variants
and the tp53 gene mutation is present in
15 of 16 in the samples so it's in it
there's a few different sample types in
this in this project and so we know you
know which gene should drop out you know
when we start doing some comparisons so
it's a nice data set now of course when
you're working with your own date data
set you may or may not know you know
which genes to expect and so you know
and that will affect how you apply the
filters and the software you may be more
or less stringent on the filtering
depending on what the expectation is so
the work flow through our software is to
start with the exome data sets these are
typically fast cue files if you download
them from the short read archive they
are in a proprietary format that you
convert the sra format those get
converted fast queue and we also
download a human reference genome
package from the DNA star website and
you seek man engine as the assembler and
so sick man engine is where we'll look
first I'll show you the interface it
produces a BAM file output that includes
many different accessory files and those
files really make the user experience in
our downstream analysis tools a great
experience so as I really think that
it's the one best interfaces that you
can use for looking at aligned data and
doing this analysis so sick man pro is
the next point that will take a look and
then we'll have different groups again
web different variation reports for
cancer and control groups and finally we
use the array star to rule to do the
wide-scale associations between the two
different groups and by applying some
filtering we can identify either
candidate genes or snips of interest
from these groups so this is the
workflow and again this is part of the
laser gene genomic sweet these three
components of software so we'll start
with seek man engine and seek man engine
again is a is a 64-bit program and it
runs on on
Mac PC and Linux it's also available on
the cloud and it's really designed to be
as easy to use as is possible and the
hope is that you can make some simple
selections and we'll show a number of
screens here for setting up the project
and it needs to be simple yet powerful
and also it needs to accommodate a wide
range of different project types and so
on the first page we just start with a
new assembly project then we choose the
type of project and again this reveals a
wide range in the functionality is a the
assembly algorithm that's used for
eczema sembly really is quite different
than that an assembler that you would
use for metagenomic or 16s RNA and so as
the user makes the selection the
software and you pick the workflow the
underlying parameters the optimal
parameters are tweaked or changed so the
algorithm can flex a little bit to
accommodate the different types of data
so again you just make the selection and
move to the next page this is where we
set up our project files so we can name
the project we select an output folder
and we also select a temporary file
location so again the temporary file
location if we refer back to the slide
earlier with the hardware setup the
temporary files are written to a scratch
disk it's a dedicated disk that we can
plug into our computer and the files are
written and then they're removed when
the assembly is done and that's really a
key to get the best performance from our
software is to have a dedicated drive to
do that then we select template files
the template files are can be fast the
files or GenBank files a variety of
different file types if you're working
with the main model organisms a good
choice argentum template packages and
these can be downloaded from the DNA so
our website so here's a just a snapshot
of our website and you can see some of
organisms here from the from the top of
the list and so we build these packages
and they contain the annotated
chromosome sequences in GenBank format
they also contain the DB snip database
files and then with human will also have
the cancer cosmic database and the dirt
database and so these can be downloaded
and used by the assembler up front so if
you supply the cement engine with this
information it can start to do
statistical snip calls as the data is
streaming through the assembler so the
assembly times that we looked at early
in the benchmarks that actually includes
assembly gapping statistical snip
calling and building the BAM output file
so all of this is being preflighted and
done ahead of time so then we can input
the sequence data files as well the data
files can be specified by read
technology and so we are compatible with
alumina long and short reads Ion Torrent
454 PacBio and as we select the read
technology again the parameters reflects
to make best use of the different
technologies and so there are different
optimal parameters for each one of the
platforms so I can load it in this case
paired-end alumina data and I can then
select if I want multiple sample data or
if I want to run those samples as
separate projects so for instance if I
have eight exomes and I want to as my
controls I could put all eight exons
into one bam file into one project and I
can then look at the bam file and
analyze the samples together so in some
cases it's very nice to have the samples
align together so I can look at the
alignment of all of them however at some
point with exomes if he comes unwieldy
to have too much data in one project if
your coverages are thousands of X deep
then we start to run into some just some
logistics of handling that much data so
then we can run these as separate
projects so for instance if I have a hug
human exomes worth of data and I need to
analyze them I'll select the app the
option to run them separately and that
will create 100 separate output assembly
files so it's a really nice easy way to
provide high throughput to these very
large data sets just select these
options um should also comment on
unpaired versus paired reads we handle
both of these so engine can take a mix
of unpaired impaired if we do have
paired data you'll provide an insert
size and then you can also see the group
name which is derived from the file name
this can be customized as well so you
can add a custom name to your samples or
your sets that you're assembling then
there's some assembly options that can
be selected the assembly options there's
a kind of a basic set that is set by
default depending on the project
workflow and also the sequencing
platform the single most important
parameter is the minimum match
percentage and for Illumina data that
set at ninety-three percent and that's
the percent that the the sequence read
must match the template in order to
align and so it's a fairly stringent
number at ninety-three percent this can
also be customized so if you want a more
stringent assembly you can increase this
to 93-97 sometimes even ninety-nine
percent usually we don't assemble it
100% so that's the one parameter that
you might change to either increase or
decrease the assembly to your template
also tell the assembly employed II of
the genome so that it can do the correct
statistical snip calls so if the
algorithm knows it's supposed to be a
plate or diploid or a population then
that that aids in calculating p values
for the snips i did expand there is an
advanced options here as well and
there's layout which we're not seeing
here but layout are more knobs and dials
that we can adjust and alignment as well
and then there's also sniff Advanced
Options and under the snip option
you can see that there's some filters
that are applied by default and this
helps to remove some of the sequencing
noise again when we're assembling
hundreds of millions or billions of
reeds there's going to be quite a few
sequencing errors you know amongst all
those reeds and so we apply some very
minimal filtering to remove much of the
sequencing noise from the data set we
should also point out that there's a
Help button here the help in sequin
engine is contextual and so if you want
to know exactly what the different
parameters are doing can click on help
and everything here will be defined so
again the sequin engine wizard this
interface is designed to really be as
easy as possible to set up and customers
generally brand new customers who have
never run assemblies before I can have
success you know right away and it's
very easy to set the assemblies up and
what's happening in the background is a
script is being written and I just like
to point this out for for customers that
might be more advanced users so if you
for instance are familiar or comfortable
with running command-line programs you
can take the script and you can run this
assembler from the command line if
that's how you choose to run it so you
may have ways to modify your scripts and
and and maybe have more automation for
running the assembly you may connect us
with the pipeline or data for pipeline
that you have you click when we click
assemble the assembly roll this window
will change into a log the log will show
you the progress of the assembly if
there's any airs or at what point it is
in the assembly and when it's finished
there will be a report here in this
window and then a button that allows you
to automatically open the assembly in
seek man pro which becomes the first
level of analysis so seek man Pro will
allow us to do a number of different
things we can look for snips we can look
for structural variations we can
visualize our sem
ways so structural variations can be
identified on through the structural
variation report and it's just an
interactive report that lists reference
position lengths and the type of
structural variant that's present
whether it's an insertion a deletion or
an endo a variant that has both
qualities and we get an idea of what
samples occurring in coverage the
feature that's occurring so this is an
interactive report that will allow me to
go two points in the assembly so I can
click on a deletion for instance and
what opens up is what's called our
strategy view but really is more like a
genome think more like a genome browser
view and so we're looking at in this
view is a depth of coverage plot and we
have some feature annotations that are
in red and green and what's highlighted
here are the pink or purple reads that
flank the deletion site so it's a way to
go and visualize where these arrows are
and say well there's a deletion detected
here here's the raw evidence for why
that deletion is there so I can go in
and confirm structural variation so that
might be one aspect of your analysis
however most most people that are doing
this this type of work will also want to
look for snips and mrs. will spend most
of the webinar is looking at snips and
and comparing them so the snip table in
Siegman pro really is the working space
for most of the analysis and the snip
table then is there's kind of two parts
there's the header at the top the header
at the top contains a series of filters
that allow us then to filter and focus
down on snips of interest each row in
the snip report is a different variation
in one of the samples and then each
column contains different bits of
information and I can control it's in
the column by I can right click on this
header and I can make different columns
appear or disappear depending on what
I'm interested in and so
with projects the size of X own projects
the goal really is to try to narrow down
the variance to a list that is
potentially interesting and so of course
that's going to vary depending on what
you're interested in but so I can show
you what some of the filters are doing
we have in the upper left corner show
all snips that can differentiate between
and filter between novel snips and known
snips so snips that are in DB snip that
have RS numbers will be the annotated
snips and they show up in the column
here that is has the DB snip ID and
these numbers in this column are the RS
numbers and so I can click on a snip and
do a lookup of that snap there's also
filters for depth there's also filters
for whether the snip occurs and creates
a coding change and that's what supplied
in this particular instance or you might
show all the snips you can also sort by
peanut ref which is a probability value
so there's a number of different ways to
filter and it's very interactive and
it's a nice place to apply different
filters and see what the results might
be the columns then I'll let's go
through a few of them the M ideas the
sample the group name for that
particular snip we have a reference
position whether it's a snip or an in
del reference based called base there's
a genotyping call the impact on the
protein the percent of the snip occurs
the probability value then we have DB
snip cosmic and gert again cosmic is the
cancer database from the Sanger
Institute group is a evolutionary
conservation score a user ID which which
I'll comment more on a little bit later
but user ID is any custom snips that if
we verified snips and we know we've
looked at them we can make an annotation
and again differentiate between snips
that are known and unknown and then of
course we have all different feature
types and protein change so the snip
report really is
becomes that working area it allows you
to really verify variations and to drill
down and look at those variations so the
the databases that we link up to also
you know really provide nice ways to
find snips that may be interesting again
when you're sorting through thousands or
millions of snips on the DB snip
database if I click on a snip that has
an RS number I can automatically go to
that page in the database and you can
see here's an RS number of 104 51 05 and
we can get all the allelic break down
for that snip and all the information
about that annotated snip and cosmic
which is growing now which is a list of
somatic mutations in cancer so if you
have cancer datasets be cosmic number
also allows you to look up specific
mutations known to be involved with
cancer and then the group scores from
the side--oh lab those are nice rip
stores are nice because they are a
conservation score a sign via comparison
of different humans and I believe
different primates and so higher numbers
indicate a more conserved base it may
occur in coding or non-coding regions
and it's a way really to differentiate
between you know if you have a large
number of nonsynonymous snips its way to
differentiate between those that may may
be more or less interesting so sick man
pro then is gives you some really nice
views of the assemblies so the snip
report is usually the starting point and
then you can click on a snip in a snip
report and it will bring you to that
point in the alignment so it'll it'll
open up the alignment view so this top
window we can see a an alignment view of
three samples in it in this case and the
three samples had this yellow
highlighted area which is a pseudo
consensus and the pseudo consensus will
show us the variant base so we can see
some blue colored variations that are
occurring and so we can collapse
multiple samples down so three exomes
you know maybe it's 10x
collapse them down kind of see them
together I can also expand the this is
human chromosome 1 so I can see the
annotations at that point I can scroll
back and forth again it's a great great
view for looking at the data I can also
look at the assembled reads there are
twisty triangles by the name if I click
on one of the triangles we get this
other window which will expand the view
and I can see the aligned data and the
actual basis with the snips and really a
best way to evaluate if you can try out
a demo of our software you really get a
feel for how well this interacts the way
that we handle the BAM files allows us
to scroll through these assemblies very
efficiently and the user experience is
top-notch so it's a really smooth user
experience much improved over many of
the genome browsers that kind of labor
to try to work with bam files they labor
as you try to move up upstream or
downstream this is very fast and very
responsive so I did comment on custom
snip so as we do the sniff calling and
if you're looking for novel snips in
particular that may not be in DB snip
you can go in and confirm look at the
alignment and go back to the snip report
and the first column is a question mark
by default where the snips are not
confirmed but if you visualize a snip
and you think it's real you can confirm
that by selecting them and when you
confirm novel snips and then save the
report what will happen is we'll get a
custom user database file that's
automatically written and this is this
will be written back to the the genome
template package that was used for the
assembly and so it's a great way to make
a record and keep track of snips that
you verified and you can reuse this it
writes the file back to the genome
template package so if i run another
assembly those snips that have
identified will have this user ID and i
can then differentiate those novel steps
that aren't in DB snip yet but I've
already verified
so it's a great way to keep track of
snips and start to build your own custom
of sniff database so so seek man is
great for looking at the assemblies and
verifying snips and looking at you know
a handful of samples at a time but if we
need to scale the project up or if you
need to make associations between large
scale projects and it it could be exomes
like this cancer at some data set it
could just be some targeting to genes
even fifty jeans if you have enough
samples it can be quite daunting to
compare which snips are in common or
which snips are unique to different
groups and so we developed some tools
and erased our to handle snip
information to pull that out of the seat
man engine assembly files and then
compare that data and not now erased art
does many different things so you can
think of it as a analyze that can
compare different sets of information so
it could be RNA seek data and if its RNA
secrets comparing gene expression values
and it was can import microarray data so
i can compare micro and RNA seek i can
bring in ships igor mi RNA or copy
number variation and i can actually
bring in different data sets for
different types of experiments so if i
want to see how my snips may have
affected some gene expression i could
bring in a snip set plus an RNA seek
data set and look for genes in common
that have been affected so it's a great
place for g wash tight analysis and can
handle huge amounts of data and provides
the user interface that we can filter
through the data easily and find jeans
or snips of interest so so the starting
point for array star is to start a snit
project and we can add our sequin engine
assembly which is our BAM assembly
folder and in this case it's a single
dad assembly that contains three exomes
i could also have a folder that contains
100 excellent an array star will in
for all that information so erased are
also provides a more sophisticated means
for organizing the experiment well we're
a sick man allows you to set up
different groups array star allows you
to assign specific attributes to the
different groups and so there's many
different ways to do this in this case
we have our control exomes and prostate
cancer exomes so very simply designed
two different groups however if you have
additional experimental attributes you
can bring those in as well there are
some quick link buttons and erased our
that allow you to import and edit
attributes and what happens is you'll
get a wizard that pops up so your if
your attributes are in a an excel sheet
and you know it may be a list of your
jeans and a list of different attributes
to the experiment erased our bring
provides a wizard so that these
different attributes can be assigned to
the different experimental groups and
this can be a very tricky and difficult
thing to do if you don't have software
that provides an interface like this if
you don't have an interface then you're
stuck trying to edit large text files
and usually that's you know only
bioinformatics folks have that
capability and this kind of brings that
that kind of power to the typical user
that may not want it may not be able to
use command line tools so then an array
estar we can compare you know snips
across all the samples and so array star
has its own set table it's organized a
bit differently than the seat been
snipped table in that it really is a
summary of a lot of projects it's not
just a project so over here in these far
right columns we can see three of these
are three of our control exomes and we
have different chromosomes and reference
positions and gene names so you know for
instance we've highlighted we have
chromosome 18 at its reference position
in a gene and then that's a summary the
reference sequences of C
we have a cosmic ID DD sniff ID don't
have a group store for this one and then
we have a snip in one of the samples so
this becomes now a summary of it could
be many different assemblies and so the
challenge at this point now is really to
apply the appropriate filters to to be
able to compare the different sets and
either get jeans or snips of interest to
kind of fall out in the comparison and
so erased our provides some more
sophisticated filtering and really the
goal is to apply filters and then create
sets of either jeans or snips and
interest and then we can compare those
sets together and so there is this first
filter for sample groups and you can see
we can search at the gene or the snip
level that's really a key point whether
you're searching at either level so if
you're searching at the snip level that
usually means that there's specific
mutations at specific points that you
want to compare and you want to see if
your experiments have snipped at those
points of interest and so you can search
at that snip level and do a base pair by
bass fair comparison if you're more
interested in how genes could be
affected it doesn't really matter
exactly where the snip is occurring just
that the snip is affecting the genes in
some way on then you can do a gene level
search it's also possible in a race
start to cross back and forth so I may
have a set of snips that are interesting
and there are quick links that allow me
then to create a chat able of the genes
that are associated with those snaps and
so the eraser provides filtering then so
I can filter my groups and i can pick my
snip searching criteria and again i can
search by genotype by translation all
the different options probability snip
percent Kurt scores whether or not my
snip is in DB snip or in my custom snip
database I can
either consider that or not and this
really an array start this becomes the
primary focal point and that's applying
my filters to try to get my subsets of
interest and and so you can try multiple
different filters and create many many
different sets based on different
filtering criteria and then we can
compare those sets that's really where
we spend most of our time in a race star
it's very easy to use again we can
supply filters and do a quick search and
and once we have our sets we can compare
those sets to each other and so a Venn
diagram is a great way to compare sets
in this case I've got just my cancer and
control set and so set a and B and when
I do a Venn diagram we can see that
there's a lot of overlap between the two
and again this is that you know a gene
level but there are there is a subset
here that is specific to the cancer set
in in the right hand corner I can select
any of the intersections and either show
a table of the snips show a table of the
genes i can remember those as a set so
it allows me to you know go on to them
to the next step and make those
comparisons so doing these kind of
searches by creating multiple sets and
applying different stringent sees is
usually if you have an unknown set of
gene this case we we know what the
answer or is what some of the answers
are so it's a good way to kind of test
and see you know how things might be
done and how filters might be applied
and a good approach is apply multiple
different filters create multiple
different sets and C are we getting a
similar set of genes to drop out and
after the filters and in this data set
under many different kind of filtering
conditions tp53 as expected will drop
out and so
so that's showing that you know under
stringent or less stringent filtering
you know we're getting the results and
the genes that are showing up here are
are showing up there is another aspect
to a race car and you can see this have
two genes here that label prostate
cancer there is some additional
capability in array star to import
annotations and so we can see in this
table that I have go IDs and prostate
cancer column and these annotations
actually come from two different sources
the prostate cancer adaptation is a
custom lists and it's just a list that
that I created from just from literature
of putative prostate cancer genes in an
excel sheet so like the experimental
setups erase our can import a table and
as long as you have unique gene
identifiers I can provide a race start a
list of 50 to 60 potential prostate
cancer genes and then use that to
populate my gene table so that when I do
my search I can see you know am i
finding genes that have already been
implicated in prostate cancer so it's a
nice way to bring in additional tertiary
information and Miss case i just brought
one column in i could have brought
additional attribute columns the go IDs
which provide information on otology and
function again these are also imported
as annotations erase our will
automatically linked up with databases
for your organism and import these
annotations into your project and again
the go annotations are assigned by the
gene name so you can pull in this
information there's also another thing
to make note of some numbers that are
displayed here and these are numbers
that are assigned for the snips that are
occurring within the genes and it's a
log to scale and it's how the genes are
affected by the variation so if there's
frame shifts or stop codons or
nonsynonymous snips we'll get a higher
value here
and and we can use that too especially
if there's multiple variations occur in
in a gene and it's an accumulation of
mutation within the gene and we'll get a
larger number here so we can find
variations that are more impactful on
the genes and so again a race star
buying multiple filters we can create
gene tables then very easily so we can
go from thousands and thousands of snips
and very quickly and efficiently narrow
our search down to a handful of genes so
just a quick summary of DNA star
software the CFN engine assembler is
agnostic to sequencing platform can
handle Ion Torrent and alumina and four
or five four and unpack bio-data the
software runs either on desktop and more
recently up on the cloud the computing
costs or the hardware costs are minimal
for for the software we've designed it
to be as efficient as possible and
really to maximize the hardware that's
available on given budget desktop
computers there's multiple different
variant reports and ways the filter that
includes p values that are calculated by
bayesian statistics and we utilize DD
snip and cosmic and Gert databases on
the fly so that information is available
right away for your analysis and seek
man and of course we can pull in
information an array star from custom
databases you could add VCF files that
can annotate specific snips or you can
have just gene lists with annotation
information they can use to annotate
gene tables and the then the filtering
can be either on groups or statistics or
it can be go consortium or go pathway
analysis so it's really a wide range of
filtering tools that are available so
again the software is easy to set up
easy to use and allows us really to find
variations of interest in even a large
estate sex
so with that it like thank you if
there's questions I'll be happy to
answer them here at the end and I think
there's a few that came through um so
I'll look over here and I don't see any
questions yet so we'll make sure that we
have questions flowing through and I'll
hang around for a bit okay it doesn't
look like we have any questions right
now so I know that we will be on the the
chat pages on the virtual booth so
please feel free to visit the booth and
if you like the contact me directly feel
free to email or call and I can answer
your questions or supply you with with
demos of the software thank you